nous avons entendu ce qu'a dit jean paul
ils ont attendu peut-être plus on manque
moi on se forme arrière soit et de très
très bons acteurs à votre avis pourquoi
ça a pris plus de temps pour vous bon je
sais pas des gens qui se révèle à 25 30
ans même plutôt qu'ils ont des choses à
dire à ce moment là et puis on a
d'autres qui ont besoin de mûrir de de
se frotter un peu à la vie comme ça et
puis il ya une chose très importante
aussi c'est que belmondo a rencontré
godard moi je les ai rencontrés dans la
rue dans ses retranchements des bistrots
mais jamais sur un plateau et ça c'est
quand même assez important
alors ça nous ramène au conservatoire
conséquent 54 vous êtes sorti avec un
prix comédie mais vous aviez 23 24 ans
félicitations ça ne se voit pas je vais
pas encore plus jeunes 15 ans je sais
pas toi je veux me suivre je peux pas
faire de calcul est à peu près en soirée
dormez vous n'êtes pas venu au cinéma
immédiatement c'était le théâtre
oui pendant pendant très longtemps on
avait même un moment j'ai fait du
théâtre et du cinéma mais vous savez on
a commencé tout un groupe de comédiens
sont à commencer des petits théâtres de
la rive gauche qui s'apparentait un peu
ce que sont les cafés-théâtres
maintenant jouer dans des théâtres qui
ont disparu qui s'appelait le babylone
le noctambule terre du quartier latin la
huchette qui existe toujours et on
jouait les pièce de ionesco de brecht
enfin tout ça c'était mais à cette
époque les metteurs en scène dit de
cinéma ne s'intéressait absolument pas
aux acteurs ils considéraient que les
acteurs de théâtre étaient des
braillards des gens qui n'avaient rien
avoir à faire derrière une caméra devant
une caméra plus tôt et on a été ignorée
pendant des années alors on a fait du
théâtre mais c'était très très bien et
puis petit à petit on a commencé là joué
des petits rôles au cinéma dans des
films plus ou moins bien et puis ça
c'est venu comme ça avec le temps mais
c'est très bien c'est mai